why is it cool that a man be like a
James Bond character James Bond can go
and sleep around yet that standard when
men apply it to women it's no they want
a woman who's chased who's not
promiscuous is that fair life isn't fair
you know life isn't fair for men or
women you know depending on how you want
to Stack it up there's a lot of guys out
there today right now that are invisible
to women on the sexual Marketplace and
they're frustrated to no end guys are
expected to chase Excellence right like
men are made women are just born a woman
needs to preserve her value on the
sexual Marketplace a man needs to create
his value on the sexual Marketplace
because again men compete women's shoes
that's why the Sexes are complementary
but we've moved completely away from
that men and women have been bombarded
with this message and they're now
completely drunk on this Kool-Aid of
everything's equal men or women are the
same if you were born as a biological
male it doesn't matter call yourself a
woman you can compete with women so we
have this strange bizarre sort of thing
evolving and nobody's really doing
anything to stop it it just keeps kind
of going in that direction